hey guys justin here with the gamespot
news update it sounds like those $40
pre-order codes for the witcher 3 might
be legitimate after all digital
storefront green man gaming started
offering pre-orders for the highly
anticipated game the witcher 3 wild hunt
for forty dollars today a hefty discount
off the sixty dollar retail price
following that reveal the games
developer CD Projekt RED told GameSpot
in a statement that green man gaming
codes originated from an unknown source
and at none of the revenue from that
purchase would go to the games developer
or publisher they encouraged fans not to
buy via GMG at this time however we
reached out to green man gaming
afterward and it firmly rejected the
claim that its codes are not legitimate
a representative for the company said
that it had trying to work with CD
Projekt RED for six months but the
online retailer was ignored so the
project read could support its own
platform gog.com green man gaming CEO
paul sulyap said in a statement we like
millions of customers are huge fans of
the witcher series and have been eager
for the launch of this amazing title we
believe that CD projekt red's desire to
support their own platform by working
with retail outlets that would not
conflict with their own is greater than
that of meeting the demands of their
audience therefore we made the decision
to indirectly secure the product and
deliver it to our customers according to
solely on this means that CD Projekt RED
is getting the revenue from sales of
these games and that any additional
discount is absorbed by GMG we've
reached out to CD Projekt RED for
further comment and you can find
additional updates on gamespot com /
news